this question I asked myself why can't I
meet someone who like knocks me off my
socks and I think is hot I I I don't
know what I got knocked out of my socks
last week by somebody and I mean just
very attractive I mean I still you don't
you don't you just meet a lot of guys
where do you go at night
home just don't you go out to dinners
and parties and stuff your friends have
to be sitting sitting you next to ig
young man no I'm not living that life
Martha how do I do it well you better
start you have a lot of friends and they
should be inviting you and taking they
didn't do that for me either by the way
I was going to say that I had to do it
myself and this man who knocked
your you know he he it wasn't exactly
appropriate but um but it was it was
good for it was good for a night you
know
just